bien madame monsieur mes chers collègues
je vous propose de commencer
on essaye de d'assurer la liaison qui
sera audio maintenant avec Monsieur
Dolle problème de liaison
nous nous retrouvons donc aujourd'hui
pour une deuxième séquence d'audition
en réunion plénière dans le cadre de la
mission sur le thème formation
compétence attractivité
nous rapporteur Martine Berthet Florence
blatterix compta et Michel caneve ce
sont de l'épre objectif d'approfondir
les travaux de notre délégation
relatifs aux tensions sur les
recrutements et aux pénuries de
compétences que rencontrent les
entreprises françaises pas c'est pas
nouveau en 2019 et 2020 nous avions
publié un rapport intitulé des
compétences de toute urgence pour
l'emploi les entreprises
qui appelaient un sursaut pour assurer
que notre économie à l'heure des grandes
transitions et de la relocalisation
puisse trouver des talents dont elle a
besoin en 2021 la délégation avait
également adopté un rapport sur
l'évolution des modes de travail et les
défis managériaux visant à tirer les
conséquences des changements profonds du
travail et des formes d'emploi et à
mieux accompagner entreprises et
travailleurs
nous souhaitons aujourd'hui faire le
point sur la situation alors que les
difficultés de recrutement persistent
surtout dans certains secteurs comme la
construction l'industrie le terrier de
restauration on peut dire dans
l'économie en général par ailleurs le
concept de grande démission s'est invité
dans le débat et la quête de sens
apparaît encore plus forte
afin de mener cette réflexion nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir cette première
table ronde dédiée au croisement des
approches trois invités madame le
docteur blender Cantini économiste
senior à l'OCDE spécialiste des
questions d'emplois et de travail
notamment des questions de compétences
vous avez notamment étudié les systèmes
de formation des adultes en perspective
internationale et la structure du marché
du travail au regard des qualifications
sommes ravis de vous entendre à nouveau
aujourd'hui puisque nous vous avions
déjà sollicité en novembre 2019 pour
intervenir sur les compétences à l'heure
de l'intelligence artificielle
monsieur Tristan Dupas à Maury salut
chercheur associé au Centre d'études et
de recherche sociologique le CERS chargé
d'enseignement à l'ESCP Business School
monsieur Lupin Maury vous avez notamment
publié plusieurs articles sur la manière
dont les jeunes abordent le marché du
travail sur la grande démission et le
sens du travail et puis Monsieur
Philippe Dole qui n'est toujours pas il
est pas toujours pas enfin je le cite
qui va nous joindre donc inspecteur
général des affaires sociales honoraires
qui interviendra en visio-conférence et
ça sera plus en visioconférence mais en
audio
et qui est auteur du rapport résorption
des tensions de recrutement bilan de la
démarche systémique engagée par 6
branches professionnelles rendus en
novembre dernier au ministre du Travail
ce rapport fait état des efforts
initiatives menés par les entreprises de
différents secteurs et pourra nous
présenter ces recommandations à cet
égard donc avec trois regards croisés
nous souhaiterions essayer de répondre
aujourd'hui à la question suivante des
difficultés actuelles sont-elles les
conséquences normales d'une période de
quasi pleine emploi et des
bouleversements liés à la crise
sanitaire économique de 2020 ou bien
traduit-elle des phénomènes plus
profonds il s'agisse d'une évolution
sociétale du rapport au travail ou bien
d'inefficacité structurelle de nos
systèmes de formation et de soutien à
l'emploi
surtout qu'elle doit être selon vous le
rôle et la réponse des pouvoirs publics
donc vous cédez la parole pour un propos
liminaire d'une durée de 5 minutes
chacun dans l'ordre de présentation et
puis nos trois rapporteurs vous
interrogeront à leur tour avant que nous
ne prenions les questions de nos
collègues
je vous prierai bien veiller à utiliser
vos micros lors de la prise de parole
nécessaire pour la bonne captation de
nos échanges et la retranscription du
compte-rendu enfin à l'issue de la Table
Ronde ne vous demanderons de bien
vouloir envoyer vos réponses au
questionnaire
traditionnels qui vous a été adressé
pour les compléments d'information voilà
je vous remercie je laisse la parole à
Madame Cantini je veux démarrer
merci à vous merci beaucoup pour cette
introduction je vais juste mettre la
France un peu en contact international
et donc les méga tendance de notre point
de vue continue à transformer les
besoins de compétences la prochaine
prochaine slide s'il vous plaît alors
je pense que c'est pas encore
la précédente
c'était la deuxième
c'est la régie qui est là
la deuxième voilà la deuxième mais si
vous mettez un light show ça devrait
marcher mieux peut-être
non ça marche ça marche sur l'écran là
mais pas sur
la deuxième et donc ce que je disais de
toute façon que les voilà les méga
tendances continuent à changer donc un
peu ce que vous disiez donc il y a
sûrement un élément structural parce
qu'on a effectivement des changements
structural sur ma chaîne du travail et
qui fait qui font que le besoin de
compétences change mais il y a eu aussi
des éléments conjoncturels si on peut
les appeler conjoncturels donc sûrement
la crise du covid qui a effectivement
un peu accéléré l'adoption de nouvelles
technologies qui a aussi changé la
formation donc l'utilisation de
technologie dans le contexte de la
formation et la crise du coût de la vie
qui est faite qui affecte effectivement
certains secteurs plus que d'autres et
donc certains adultes surtout dans les
secteurs productifs des énergies non
renouvelables que d'autres et tous ces
méga tendance ont effectivement aussi
augmenter les inégalité qui existait
déjà auparavant et ces évolutions en
fait soit la demande et l'offre de
compétences et génère des déséquilibres
donc des déficits de compétences des
équilibre en compétence prochaine donc
si je me focalise sur deux tendances en
particulier du côté on a les avancements
technologiques de l'autre la transition
verte sans pour autant
vouloir dire que les autres donc le
vieillissement de la population et aussi
la globalisation ne sont plus importants
mais on en a parlé plus longtemps dans
le passé maintenant on se focalise plus
sur ceux des aspects donc du point de
vue de la technologie on a effectivement
mis à jour un peu l'étude que je vous
avais présenté la dernière fois 2019 en
se focalisant plus spécifiquement sur
l'intelligence artificielle et en fait
ce qu'on voit dans les dernières années
depuis l'étude précédente c'est qu'il y
a eu effectivement il y a toujours des
tâches et des compétences et des qui
peuvent être automatisés de plus en plus
et c'est celle les par exemple la
capacité les capacités psychomotrices la
capacité de travailler dans un espace
étroit par exemple des positions
inconfortables etc donc ça ça reste très
automatisable et ça a été si vous voulez
encore plus automatiser grâce à leur
intelligence artificielle parce que par
le passé la vraie dextérité manuelle
était quand même encore assez difficile
à automatiser après il y a quand même
des compétences qui qui font plus partie
de d'emploi un peu plus haut qualifiés
et qui sont automatisables aujourd'hui
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle et
on parle par exemple du raisonnement des
Lutti finitifs de la capacité de lecture
de la créativité même qui peuvent être
automatisés et qui font partie donc ça
affecte un peu plus les emplois à haut
niveau de qualification et il reste
quand même toujours des goulots
d'étranglement et ça c'est effectivement
la capacité de résoudre les problèmes
complexes la gestion de haut niveau les
interactions sociales si on traduit ça à
leur interne qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour les emplois prochaine slide en fait
ce qu'on voit ce que tous les emplois
sont un peu affectés donc on
reste quand même dans une situation où
les emplois peut qualifiés sont les plus
affectés pourquoi en gros parce que tous
les emplois inclus des aptitudes des
compétences qui sont facilement en
automatisables et des compétences qui
constituent des goulots d'étranglement
dans les emplois peu qualifiés il y a
quelques goulots d'étranglement mais il
y a surtout des tâches des compétences
facilement automatisables donc ils sont
quand même plus affectés sans pour
autant être vraiment à risque de
disparaître complètement sauf quelques
exceptions mais ils vont changer très
dramatiquement de l'autre côté on a des
emplois qui effectivement sont affectés
par l'intelligence artificielle mais
parce que certaines tâches
au niveau managérial peuvent aujourd'hui
être automatisés mais ces emplois
comportent quand même une grande partie
de tâches qui sont toujours pas
automatisables donc ils sont affectés
ils changent on a quand même besoin de
riskining habski pour ses adultes mais
on n'est plus dans la dans le
remplacement potentiel plutôt du travail
avec la technologie et si on traduit ça
interne d'emploi en France on peut dire
que les emplois où il y a une partie
très importante de tâches qui peuvent
être automatisées constituées à peu près
10% des emplois contre si vous voulez
les deux extrêmes c'est 18% en Hongrie
6% au Royaume-Uni là ça c'est une
tendance donc dans la technologie vers
le haut donc une demande très haute de
compétences par contre si on regarde la
transition verte prochaine slide en fait
on a encore un discours assez mélangé
donc en fait ce qu'on sait c'est que les
emplois détruisent c'est souvent dans la
production dans des secteurs quand même
comme je disais avant des secteurs
d'énergie non-renouvelables des emplois
à ces manuels etc de l'autre côté c'est
encore pas totalement clair si les
emplois créés c'est vraiment des emplois
à très haut niveau de compétences des
ingénieurs des scientifiques etc ou si
c'est des emplois de techniciens donc il
y a des études qui soutiennent en fait
que la demande va se va être une demande
de compétence plus élevée mais pas à
très haut niveau plutôt des compétences
de moyens niveau dans des techniciens
par exemple ce qui ferait que comme on
l'a vu du point de vue de la technologie
on a vu une polarisation donc une
demande très forte des deux côtés donc
une part croissante des emplois au
niveau de compétences sur la croissance
des emplois bas niveau de compétences et
pas au milieu donc une réduction des
emplois à niveau moyen de compétences
pour la transition verte cela est moins
clair parce qu'on sait pas encore enfin
on l'a vu un niveau sectorial mais pas
au niveau global où vont se concentrer
les emplois créés
prochain point
alors je vais essayer de d'être bref
parce qu'on a pas beaucoup de temps mais
les pénuries professionnels
qui résulte de ces disons de ces
tendances en fait sont assez mélangés là
c'est l'image des hommes pour la France
c'est ce qu'on voit c'est des pénuries
dans les secteurs qu'on connaisse tout
de la santé de la de l'enseignement mais
aussi les niveaux les ingénieurs les
scientifiques mais aussi de pénurie dans
des emplois relativement bacs qualifiés
comme la production alimentaire les la
préparation alimentaire les
constructions et donc les chauffeurs par
exemple et l'enjeu pour les adultes est
assez important un accès Lite en fait ce
qu'on voit en France c'est qu'il y a
encore 20% d'adultes qui ont des niveaux
de littératie et de numération qui sont
très bas donc qui sont peut-être dans
l'emploi donc c'est il faut dire que
beaucoup d'entre eux effectivement ont
un emploi mais donc le vrai un jeu ça
commence faire la transition pour ses
adultes vers des emplois que de toute
façon vont demander des qualifications
plus élevées c'est des adultes qui
effectivement au niveau de littératie
numéraire interpréter les informations
les plus simples les chiffres les plus
simples mais pas
ils ont pas les capacités pour s'engager
sur des tâches plus complexes
prochain donc là je vais dire très
rapidement il y a effectivement un coup
si on n'agit pas un coup pour les
individus un coup pour les entreprises
et un coût après un niveau national de
compétitivité de productivité
un prochain point et alors la
malheureusement il y a pas beaucoup
d'adultes qui participent à la formation
chaque donc en France chaque année il y
a 32% des AD qui participent à la
formation
10% qui auraient voulu participer mais
disent qu'ils ont eu des donc ils font
face à des barrières principalement le
manque de temps en France ce qui pour
des raisons professionnelles et
personnelles ce qui se détache en France
c'est aussi que il y a beaucoup
d'adultes qui qui disent qu'ils ont pas
le soutien de l'employeur donc il y en a
12% comparé à peu près à 5% dans la
moyenne de l'OCDE donc c'est un peu plus
que la normale et en plus il y a quand
même 60% d'adultes qui disent qui il y
avait pas de
formation qui leur a voulu entreprendre
mais qu'ils ont pas entrepris ça peut
vouloir dire qu'ils ont qu'ils étaient
pas motivés à se former mais c'est une
interprétation très simple parce qu'on
pourrait aussi imaginer qu'il perçoivent
les barrières comme étant très élevé
donc ils sont découragés où on pourrait
imaginer aussi qu'ils ont pas su
identifier la formation qui soit
vraiment adaptée à leurs besoins et en
plus prochain slide ce qui ne se forment
pas c'est surtout des adultes qui ont le
plus besoin donc les adultes le moins
qualifiés les plus âgés ceux qui
travaillent dans un PME prochaine slice
en fait on sait aussi que la formation
n'est pas forcément adaptée aux besoins
toujours adaptés aux besoins du marché
du travail même quand même quand elle
est pourvu des entreprises on trouve
qu'il y a beaucoup d'entreprises même
parmi les disons pas les
micro-entreprises donc avec de 10 au
plus employés qui n'évaluent pas leurs
besoins de compétences beaucoup de la
formation grande partie de la formation
quand même formation pour des raisons
réglementaires aux formations
obligatoires et quand on regarde la
correspondance entre un jeu stratégique
pour l'entreprise et contenu de la
formation il y a pas il y a souvent pas
beaucoup de correspondances entre les
deux alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
peut-être ce qu'on va discuter
aujourd'hui dernière slide alors nous on
a tout un framework voilà de de d'action
donc il y a des actions pour augmenter
la participation à l'inclusivité de la
formation des éléments pour améliorer
laignement de la formation aux besoins
du marché du travail des éléments qui
sont visés à augmenter l'impact et la
qualité de la formation et donc l'impact
que ça peut avoir pour les individus
pour les entreprises et pour le pays
finalement et dans tout ça une grande
importance du financement et surtout de
la co-responsabilité de tous les acteurs
donc gouvernement entreprises et
particuliers évidemment et après une
grande importance aussi de la
gouvernance du système pour que on sait
la formation des adultes elle est
complexe en termes de gouvernance par
rapport à la formation des jeunes qui
est normalement la responsabilité du
ministère de l'Éducation rien que au
niveau du gouvernement on a plusieurs
ministères qui sont effectivement
concernés et il y a beaucoup d'acteurs
il y a les entreprises il y a les
syndicats il y a les particuliers il y a
les instituts de formation etc donc il y
a beaucoup de partenaires qui doivent
être tous participé de certaines façons
de façon collaborative à la gouvernance
du système
merci Madame pour cette propos
introductif donc passe la parole à
Monsieur
Dupas Maury
bonjour à tous Tout d'abord je tenais à
vous remercier pour votre invitation et
l'intérêt que vous portez à mes travaux
je m'appelle Tristan dupas-maury je suis
chercheur en sciences sociales et
dernièrement on m'a régulièrement
demandé de réagir sur le phénomène de
grandes démission et sur ce qu'il nous
dit du rapport à l'emploi
on a beaucoup entendu parler
l'expression beaucoup pour ne pas dire
partout et elle a toujours accompagné
d'un certain flou que j'aimerais
éclaircir pour débuter mon intervention
car rien n'est plus simple en réalité
que le début d'une grande démission
il suffit à la suite d'une crise
sanitaire d'attirer l'attention sur une
hausse des démissions observées dans une
grande économie occidentale en
l'occurrence les États-Unis ou 38
millions de salariés quittent leur
emploi en 2021 il s'agit ensuite de
désigner ce phénomène par plusieurs
expressions dont le succès spectaculaire
et proportionnel au mystère qui les
entoure the great trace nation de
bigweet the greatest show
utilisez-les pour signaler
l'augmentation des démissions constatées
dans d'autres pays dont la France
la contamination menaçante du virus du
désengagement salarial exportera et
importera les questions qu'il s'agit de
trancher dans cette situation inédite
devenue sans frontières est-elle liée un
simple effet de rattrapage de la suite
d'une crise sanitaire qui a tout figé
faut-il plutôt y voir le signe du
démotivation brutale des salariés ou
d'un désenchantement antérieur que la
crise ne fait que révéler remettez en
cause des conditions ou une organisation
du travail particulière
prenez donc en somme un phénomène
observable des noms facilement
consommables une contamination
internationale des interrogations
politiques et sociales
la grande démission au sens de
raz-de-marée imprévu n'existe pourtant
que pour succomber à la première analyse
en France le nombre de démissions est
haut mais il n'est pas inédit ni
inattendu compte tenu du contexte
économique comme le rappelle la DARES le
taux de démission est un indicateur
cyclique bas durant les crises il
augmente en période de reprise car les
opportunités d'emploi se font plus
nombreuses
qui rend plus aisé de prendre la
décision de démissionner la hausse du
taux de démission apparaît normal en
lien avec la reprise
le phénomène n'est pas plus avéré aux
États-Unis des professeurs à la Harvard
Business School constate que sur une
période sur une période longue la
tendance des démissions est à la hausse
depuis plus d'une décennie bien avant la
pandémie
le sujet n'est donc pas une explosion
inédite et subite des démissions mais
cette augmentation chronique du taux de
démission c'est elle qui pose l'énigme
du consentement au travail plutôt que le
phénomène ponctuel qui occupe l'espace
du débat
de la deux hypothèses première hypothèse
le taux de croissant le taux croissant
des missions manifeste la vitalité de
l'économie et les opportunités offertes
par le marché du travail aux salariés
deuxième hypothèse et c'est celle qui
est souvent retenue c'est un marqueur de
l'insatisfaction grandissante des
salariés vis-à-vis de leur travail et de
la relation d'emploi qui leur est
proposé
sans doute que ces deux hypothèses sont
vraies dans une certaine mesure
des questionnements profonds sont devant
les entreprises et les organisations et
beaucoup d'entre elles pour des raisons
de performance notamment apportent un
réel soin à comprendre ce qui se joue
actuellement pour s'adapter au fond les
principaux leviers pour les entreprises
sont connues il concerne les conditions
transactionnelles salaires temps de
travail accès à la formation et le
contenu et l'organisation du travail
intérêt du travail qualité du management
et des relations au travail
c'est surtout tout le contrat
psychologique c'est-à-dire les
conditions subjectives du travail qu'il
faut repenser pour parer cette
difficulté croissante à attirer et
retenir les salariés
la fin du travail n'est pas pour tout de
suite dans certaines communes
communautés grecque seuls ceux qui ne
travaillaient pas vivaient vraiment
malgré le catastrophisme parfois lié à
la grande démission on en est pas là
la grande démission n'a que l'allure
d'une révolution au sens de changement
brusques mais nous devons l'empêcher de
se transformer en simple révolution un
tour complet sur soi
grande démission et crise sanitaire ont
permis le surgissement dans l'actualité
des mutations du rapport au travail
c'est dans un processus historique au
long cours qu'il s'agit de les
réinscrire
c'est ce que ce que j'ai appelé la
grande rétention représente la tentation
d'un point d'empêcher un nouveau rapport
au travail de naître alors même que
l'ancien se meurt de cette tentative
parfois désespérée ne peut sortir que
l'insensé
malgré les incompréhensions qui existent
entre les aspirations des entreprises et
des salariés la transformation en cours
pourrait être conforme à l'intérêt des
deux parties
la construction du rapport au travail
est individuelle mais repose également
sur la construction de cette relation
profondément collective ensemble les
salariés dessinent les fondations d'une
critique collective du marché du travail
et de l'organisation des entreprises qui
ne tient qu'à nous d'entendre de
reformuler et d'accepter
merci pour cet éclairage et alors là il
y aura aussi beaucoup de questions
j'espère c'est sûr alors est-ce que
Monsieur Doll est accessible ok donc on
continue on va on va donc passer
aux questions de nos rapporteur
peut-être commencer Michel Canevet
merci monsieur le Président merci à nos
deux intervenants effectivement pour
leurs éclairages
on a évoqué vous avez évoqué madame
Cathy dit tout à l'heure la question de
l'automatisation des tâches
effectivement
on voit que de plus en plus dans
l'industrie
de tâches automatismes mais on observe
que sur le secteur de l'emploi dans en
France
il y a un certain nombre de métiers dont
les tâches sont difficilement
automatisables dans l'état et sur
lesquels il apparaît qu'il y est une
réelle pénurie de main d'oeuvre je veux
notamment parler des métiers de l'aide à
domicile de l'aide à aux personnes de
du travail dans les institutions
sociales et médico-sociales en
particulier des conducteurs routiers
également
des serveurs
et des cuisiniers dans l'hôtellerie
restauration enfin voilà donc il y a un
certain nombre de secteurs où il qu'il y
ait cette cette pénurie en tout cas
c'est là qu'on entend beaucoup
d'employeurs effectivement nous dire
nous n'arrivons pas à trouver la main
d'oeuvre que dont nous avons besoin
malgré le fait qu'il y ait effectivement
3 millions d'inscrits en abaissé
à Pôle emploi et 5 millions 4 d'inscrits
de manière globale c'est-à-dire un
chiffre tout à fait
considérable jusqu'où pensez-vous qu'on
puisse aller dans la baisse du chômage
aujourd'hui à taux de l'ordre de 7%,
c'est-à-dire que 20% je crois
vous le plein d'emploi vous le situez à
quel niveau
à peu près
alors je ne suis
pas je ne sais pas spécifiquement pour
pour la France donc je m'exprime pas sur
le plein emploi mais je trouve quand
même que le discours que vous faisiez
c'est très intéressant nous en effet on
a regardé pour certaines emplois en
pénurie dont pas spécifiquement pour la
vente mais je pourrais regarder pour la
France spécifiquement aussi de voir si
effectivement
les tâches automatisa enfin
l'automatisation pourraient aider pour
ces emplois en pénurie donc on a fait
une correspondance des tâches par
rapport enfin des professions en pénurie
et les tâches de ses professions si
elles peuvent être automatisées ou non
et en effet disons que la
l'image est assez mélangée donc il y a
des aspects qui peuvent être automatisés
d'autres qui ne peuvent pas l'être et
vous avez pointé le doigt effectivement
je pense surtout dans le secteur
du soin aux personnes c'est vraiment
[Musique]
difficile alors il y a beaucoup de
tâches interpersonnelles si vous voulez
donc exactement ces interactions
sociales qui peuvent très difficilement
être automatisés alors la mécanique des
soins peut-être pour être automatisé
mais il y a quand même tout
l'interpersonnel qui a très difficile à
automatiser et de plus alors nos études
sont théoriques donc c'est vraiment une
analyse des tâches après il y a
l'élément de l'adoption et l'élément
surtout d'un cimetier de soins aux âgés
et de soins nos enfants par exemple
garde d'enfants etc c'est l'élément
d'acceptabilité sociale et je dirais
partout dans le monde ce n'est pas le
cas alors on sait que on le fait parfois
dans certains maisons de retraite il y a
des tâches qui peuvent effectivement
être automatisés mais personne va
confier dans la plupart des pays leur
parents
âgés de leurs enfants un petit en bas
âge à aux soins
uniques de de
automatiser donc il y a effectivement
cet élément d'acceptabilité sociale et
le exact en particulier parce que ces
éléments d'interaction sociale ne
peuvent pas être répliquées
pour après il y a l'autre catégorie
d'emploi je pense que ça effectivement
un discours très complexe qui varie par
secteur dans tout ce qui est
effectivement la cuisine par exemple les
serveurs dans les restos la préparation
alimentaire etc bah je pense qu'on a
fait on a vu quand même des progrès
enfin on a vu les machines automatiques
dans certains restos pour les ordres en
automatique j'ai vu aussi mais c'est un
anecdote évidemment mais un resto je
pense sur Paris où le cuisinier est un
robot donc je passe encore expérimenté
la qualité mais apparemment c'est pas
mal je crois qu'il fait des pizzas par
ailleurs mais effectivement c'est
entièrement en automatisé je pense que
dans la donc dans la dans l'alimentation
au moins l'alimentation à grands
échelles pas forcément évidemment la
haute cuisine française on peut quand
même faire des progrès je pense que dans
ce contexte il faut aussi considérer
comme le disait monsieur Amaury
de la qualité des emplois de la
tractivité de certains emplois aux
États-Unis par exemple on a vu
effectivement des pénuries très
importantes dans le secteur justement de
préparations alimentaires et on se
demande où sont ces gens qu'est-ce qui
lui est arrivé comment ils peuvent se
permettre parce que effectivement
c'était quand même des emplois à bas
salaire comme il peut se permettre de
dire je travaillais plus parce que les
conditions de travail ne me conviennent
plus et en fait ce qu'on a constaté dans
certains études ça qui sont passées au
secteur par exemple commercial de la
vente en magasin parce que ça rapporte
plus les conditions de travail sont
meilleures les horaires sont plus
encadrés donc je pense qu'il y a
effectivement un discours assez complexe
derrière tout ces pénuries qui n'est pas
toujours le même qui est en partie voilà
une question de conditions de travail en
partie des éléments plus structurels de
changement mais c'est pas un discours
unique je crois
et pour Monsieur Tristan Dupas Amaury
est-ce que le phénomène de démission que
vous avez évoqué dans votre propos
introductif est-ce qu'il est plus marqué
en France que dans d'autres pays vous
avez notamment cité les chiffres pour
les États-Unis est-ce qu'il est vraiment
plus marqué dans notre pays ou pas et
pour notre pays comment considérez-vous
les raisons
alors il y a eu des études comparatives
justement qui se sont intéressés à cette
hausse du taux de démission à la fois en
Europe et aux États-Unis
alors on a eu des accélérations du taux
de démission par exemple au Royaume-Uni
en France
en Espagne également alors que le taux
de chômage est relativement plus élevé
en revanche ce qu'on a constaté c'est
que dans des pays où les principes comme
la co-détermination était un peu plus
institutionnalisé au sein des
entreprises l'accélération était plus
faible donc je pense à l'Autriche je
pense à l'Allemagne etc
alors il faut toujours se méfier de la
cause de la cause de la cause unique il
y a pas une cause unique à chercher donc
je peux pas vous dire que c'est si on
instaurait une culture de la
codétermination en France comme on ne
triche ou en Allemagne il y aurait une
accélération plus faible en revanche
c'est des constats qu'on peut comment
dire qu'on peut comment dire dont on
peut donc on peut discuter en tout cas
sur
raison du taux de démission alors
au-delà du fait de du rattrapage en fait
lié qui est lié à la crise c'est à dire
que en fait si vous regardez comment
dire la hausse du taux de démission
avant la crise et après en fait si vous
voulez c'est égal c'est juste un
rattrapage au niveau des au niveau des
démissions du taux d'émission et en fait
les raisons sont très simples regardons
les secteurs qui polarisent les taux de
démission les plus élues en France vous
en avez cité quelques-uns donc vous avez
le secteur de l'enseignement de la Santé
de l'Action sociale le commerce la
réparation automobile la fabrication
agroalimentaire est loin devant le
secteur de l'hébergement et la
restauration
en fait ce sont des secteurs ou les tout
simplement les conditions de travail
sont exigeantes les niveaux de rémulat
de rémunération relativement faible et
la relation d'emploi peut qualitative
on peut chercher effectivement des
raisons extrêmement complexes mais la
réalité voilà elle est celle là
ce qui est important c'est pour moi de
distinguer les levier des conditions
transactionnelles le salaire le temps de
travail donc là on peut parler des
augmentations de salaires on peut parler
aussi de la semaine de quatre jours
aussi dont on parle beaucoup ensuite
vous avez comment dire des éléments qui
ne sont pas qui sont là qui sont pas
transactionnels qui sont plus dans
l'organisation du travail
et là par exemple aussi j'ai quelques
j'ai quelques pistes
dont je vous parlerai peut-être un peu
plus tard mais ce qui est central c'est
ce dont je parlais de mon propos
liminaire c'est la notion de contrat
psychologique
le contrat psychologique donc c'est un
courant de recherche qui est apparu dans
les années 50 qu'on connaît très bien
notamment en gestion des ressources
humaines et c'est ça part d'une
hypothèse tout à fait
simple mais c'est souvent simple en fait
dans ces cas-là c'est
l'engagement ou la motivation du salarié
elle vient d'un équilibre entre ces
contributions et c'est rétributions ce
qu'il donne et ce qu'il prend et là où
ça devient complexe c'est ce que ce
contrat psychologique il est subjectif
c'est à dire que
on peut pas seulement se baser sur les
données économiques et par exemple
augmenter tous les salaires et penser
que voilà ça s'arrêterait non c'est pas
vrai d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de
secteurs les salaires sont augmentés et
on voit quand même ce comment dire ce
phénomène et c'est là où c'est complexe
et on est dans la matière humaine c'est
que ce contrat il est il est il est à
vous vous pouvez faire le même emploi
vous avez un contrat psychologique qui
est bien différent de de votre voisin
par exemple et en fait c'est ce levier
là qui est en train de changer et voilà
la manière dont on considère en fait
notre rapport à l'emploi et c'est pour
ça que c'est extrêmement compliqué parce
que vous êtes dans une tendance au long
cours que vous dont on pourrait avoir la
tentation de stopper et je pense que ça
peut amener en fait à des enfin comment
dire à à des choix contre-productifs
par exemple on parle beaucoup de la
rétention donc aujourd'hui le défi des
entreprises c'est d'attirer et de
retenir
et donc les entreprises ont essayé de
d'activer les différents leviers au
niveau de l'organisation du travail au
niveau comment dire des salaires etc
mais la question c'est si vous retenez
quelqu'un dans une relation dont vous ne
voulez fondamentalement plus
telle qu'elle est désormais vous allez
juste retarder l'échéance et d'autres
phénomènes comme des risques
psychosociaux etc vont apparaître donc
en fait si vous voulez je pense qu'on
est entre entre
la problématique de laisser faire et en
même temps la problématique de
rééquilibrage parce que effectivement en
ce moment on pourrait se dire qu'il y a
des il y a quelques demandes
extravagantes etc etc mais c'est parce
que en fait on est dans une dans une
situation de rééquilibrage et en fait
les salariés comme les entreprises voilà
essaye d'établir ce nouvel équilibre et
du coup vous avez des demandes vous avez
des phénomènes qui apparaissent
mais voilà c'est c'est très complexe
enfin c'est assez simple et très
complexe dans le sens où complexe parce
qu'on a affaire de la matière humaine et
à de la subjectivité plus qu'à des
conditions économiques qui participent
effectivement au problème de manière
structurelle mais mais c'est autre chose
autre chose qu'ils jouent en ce moment
j'ai l'impression
sur ce point-là est-ce que j'ai entendu
une étude je suis pas penché
particulièrement dessus mais qui
divisait le le corps des salariés en
trois en trois tiers un tiers très
motivé ça correspond un peu à vos propos
c'est à dire c'est une implication
personnelle donc chacun se retrouve dans
l'un ou l'autre des groupes un tiers
très motivé très actif
très
proactif même dans son activité un tiers
qui fait juste le boulot qu'on lui
demande selon sa fiche de poste pas plus
pas moins et un tiers qui traîne les
pieds qui qui a une attitude négative
qui n'est pas satisfait du tout est-ce
que vous avez des éléments de ce type
sur la répartition est-ce que ça
correspond une réalité ou est-ce que
c'est juste un propos de de
circonstances alors je me méfie toujours
des typologies qui sont ce qu'elles sont
c'est-à-dire intellectuellement elles
nous permettent de nous figurer voilà
des situations mais sont jamais très
fine en revanche sur la question de
cette crise généralisée de l'engagement
en fait j'ai envie de vous dire que là
aussi il y a enfin pas grand chose de
nouveau
en fait les vous avez des résultats
d'enquête annuelles conduite à l'échelle
mondiale par l'Institut galop par
exemple pas par exemple
et en fait depuis des décennies on sait
que les salariés en Europe sont ceux qui
se déclarent le moins investis et parmi
les Européens les Français sont ceux qui
sont les moins investis parmi voilà les
moins investis
donc
si vous voulez voilà on en parle
aujourd'hui donc c'est le surgissement
dans l'actualité de quelque chose voilà
qui qui en fait sont dans des rapports
depuis depuis beaucoup de temps après
sur en fait sur les par exemple cette
typologie vous parlez celui qui est
démotivé etc et je pense notamment là
aussi un sujet d'actualité qui a été le
courrier de footing en fait
dans dans le rééquilibrage de votre
contrat psychologique le premier réflexe
la première stratégie que vous pouvez
avoir c'est de en réduisant votre
contribution c'est d'en faire un peu
moins mais c'est quelque chose qui date
alors non seulement des années 50 mais
qui date même vous pouvez aller voir
dans la littérature Bartoli qui voilà
Bartoli de script je sais pas si vous
avez lu mais en fait c'est un employé
donc je crois que c'est 1823 quelque
chose comme ça qui va refuser
progressivement les injonctions de son
patron et qui va dire je ne préférerais
pas le faire il réduit sa contribution
donc c'est pareil c'est le surgissement
en fait d'une stratégie juste on est
dans une phase de rééquilibrage et du
coup il y a ce phénomène qui est un peu
plus visible etc mais c'est le premier
réflexe si vous êtes un peu désengagé au
travail qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
vous allez réduire votre contribution
c'est quelque chose de très naturel
donc c'est typologie elle reflète ça sur
la proportion honnêtement je saurais pas
vous répondre et je pense que il y a
aussi beaucoup de différences selon les
groupes professionnels etc
par exemple on remarque chez les sur
investis aussi une critique comment dire
de ce qu'on a appelé loverwork même chez
les diplômés chez les traits diplômés en
fait ce fait de travailler énormément et
d'avoir ce rapport un peu agonistique au
travail ça aussi c'est quelque chose qui
est remis en question notamment par les
nouvelles générations
et voilà je pense qu'on peut échanger et
que c'est ce genre de typologie est
utile pour échanger en revanche je me
garderai de vous confirmer ou d'infirmer
une proportion sur les salariés je pense
que ça varie énormément
oui je complète juste en disant que je
pense sur l'élément de la motivation ce
qu'on a vu à le CDE toujours
en termes de surtout
des moments à l'emploi donc utilisation
de ces compétences dans l'emploi et vous
l'avez dit avant donc c'est surtout les
modes de travail en entreprise qui
peuvent effectivement être plus
motivants donc ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
analysé il y a quelques années c'est
par exemple la possibilité de travailler
en équipe la l'autonomie dans le choix
de l'ordre des tâches ou la façon en
gros de de travailler
les éléments liés à l'apprentissage de
par
les Pères et par donc l'échange avec les
collègues je pense que ça permet
effectivement ce qu'on a vu dans nos
études c'est que du côté ça permet que
les gens soient plus à engagés dans
l'emploi qu'ils utilisent mieux leurs
compétences qui les mettent à profit
dans l'emploi et ça augmente aussi le
retour sur la formation donc on a des
gens qui sont en plus d'opportunités
d'apprendre de façon informelle au
travail ce qui a finalement très
important parce que ça évite tous ces
barrières dont je parlais entre avant
non surtout la barrière de ne pas avoir
du temps ce qui est ce que tout le monde
dit est presque 40% des gens quand on
lui demande pourquoi ils se forment pas
ça ils disent je parle le temps soit
pour des raisons personnelles et de vie
de responsabilité familiale soit parce
que effectivement ils ont pas le temps
dans l'emploi donc la formation
informelle ça qui nous arrive tous les
jours parce qu'on doit se garder à jour
dans notre emploi parce qu'on apprend
des collègues parce qu'on a cette
possibilité d'essayer de façon
différente de le faire nos emplois nous
permet du côté d'apprendre de l'autre de
mettre en pratique notre apprentissage
et donc on a un retour
préserver plus élevé en termes de
salaire ou en termes de productivité sur
notre formation et ça nous permet aussi
ça permet à l'entreprise aussi meilleure
utilisation des compétences parce que
les gens généralement s'impliquent plus
en termes de vraiment
utilisation de compétences au travail
quand le contexte organisatif disons de
la de l'entreprise est elle qui permet
plus de liberté d'autonomie de
d'essayage de de communication de
travail en équipe
merci alors avant de poursuivre les
interventions des rapporteurs on va
essayer la liaison avec Monsieur doll
est-ce que vous m'entendez monsieur doll
oui je vous entends est-ce que vous
m'entendez oui ah bah voilà la liaison
est parfaite et maintenant parfaite
alors
écoutez merci allez-y
je n'ai pas mis la caméra parce que j'ai
une bande passante très mauvaise ok
merci monsieur le Président et Mesdames
Messieurs de
m'accueillir malgré les difficultés
techniques que j'ai trouvé
alors si vous le permettez Monsieur
Dolce je vais reprendre la présentation
que de vous-même que j'ai que j'ai faite
tout à l'heure
pour bien que chacun apprécie votre
votre parcours et votre profil vous êtes
inspecteur général des affaires sociales
honoraires et vous êtes l'auteur du
rapport résorption des tensions de
recrutement bilan de la démarche
systémique engagée par 6 branches
professionnelles que vous avez rendu en
novembre dernier au ministre du Travail
donc votre rapport fait état des efforts
et des initiatives menées par les
entreprises de différents secteurs et
vous pourrez évidemment nous présenter
vos recommandations à cet égard donc je
vous propose
en 5 minutes peut-être de faire un
propos liminaire et puis ensuite on
poursuivra les questions-réponses autour
des de vous-même et des deux autres
intervenants dont je vous passe la
parole
merci monsieur le Président et bien vous
dire rapidement que cette démarche est
une démarche inédite parce que
le premier ministre Jean Castex et les
partenaires sociaux avaient souhaité
travailler à la résorption des
difficultés de recrutement à partir des
prérogatives et des capacités
d'intervention des branches des branches
professionnelles alors vous savez tout
ce qui ne branche professionnelle en
réalité ce sont les acteurs paritaires
négociateur de l'accord collectif de
travail c'est-à-dire une convention
collective et qui également détermine un
certain nombre de dispositifs on va le
voir qui sont extrêmement importants
puisque ils contribuent à ce qu'on
appelle l'attractivité de l'emploi
dans cette démarche
[Musique]
des plans successifs massifs qui ont été
engagés par les pouvoirs publics qui ont
eu une forme d'utilité mais qui n'ont
pas forcément toujours porter leurs
fruits en termes d'accès à l'emploi pour
une raison d'ailleurs que je pense que
vous connaissez tous qui est le fait que
lorsque on engage des efforts de
formation long et lourds on a à la fois
on travaille sur la production de
compétences et la préparation à des
activités nouvelles ou des activités
pour lesquelles on renforce les
savoir-faire mais en même temps on
éloigne les personnes de l'emploi par le
fait même de l'activité de formation et
des travaux ont été conduits dans ce
sens qui montre que au-delà d'un délai
de l'ordre de six mois
l'avantage que procure la formation et
contrecarrer en quelque sorte par
l'éloignement du marché du travail
éloignement de l'emploi que la formation
génère donc faut trouver un point
d'équilibre c'est pour ça que les
formations en alternance sont
particulièrement appréciables alors en
dehors de cette question vous direz
également en tant que
au niveau d'une branche vitée vous allez
très vite on a plusieurs leviers
d'action qui permettent de résoudre les
questions de recrutement en tout cas les
résorber des réserver ces difficultés
la négociation collective porte sur les
rémunérations elle porte sur les
classifications elle porte également sur
les conditions de travail
les branches disposent d'un outil
important d'analyse et de prospectives
qui l'observatoire de branches qui
permet en fin de compte de réfléchir à
l'évolution des métiers et de déterminer
les futurs référentiels de compétences à
la fois pour des métiers en
transformation mais parfois pour des
métiers qui sont en pure création
la branche dispose également de
prérogatives en matière de certification
c'est-à-dire la production des diplômes
des titres des CQP et certificats de
qualification professionnelle
la capacité à définir une politique de
financement de l'apprentissage et des
contrats de professionnalisation alors
même si sur la question de
l'apprentissage est un dialogue aussi
avec France compétences d'une branche à
l'autre ces questions là sont quand même
décidé dans un cadre paritaire comme je
viens de le dire enfin la branche
dispose une capacité d'intervention avec
l'appui des pouvoirs publics et du
service public de l'emploi pour
mobiliser les entreprises comme pour
mobiliser les demandeurs d'emploi
donc cette approche structurelle elle
est évidemment complémentaire des
travaux qu'on peut mener au niveau local
on sait bien que l'emploi se joue dans
la proximité au niveau de l'entreprise
et dans la proximité du bassin d'emploi
mais si on travaille pas sur les
éléments structurels qui constituent
finalement l'offre
juridique et technique de travail on
peut s'épuiser à chercher des personnes
et leur offrir un cadre qui finalement
ne les satisfait pas
l'autre élément que je voudrais
souligner rapidement c'est le fait que
nous sommes dans un marché qui est très
concurrentiel
les
recrutements s'opèrent dans un marché à
la fois concurrentiel et contraint avec
des facteurs spécifiques des
problématiques d'âge d'accès la
formation dans les professions
réglementées
des employeurs qui recherchent un
candidat qui répond à toutes les
critères recherchés et des actifs qui
soient recherchent les meilleurs
salaires et conditions d'emplois soit ne
veulent absolument pas se tourner vers
certains métiers ou emplois pourtant en
tension
donc on observe un manque de candidature
parfois d'inadéquation du profil des
candidats
et certains métiers sont encore méconnus
ou bien de façon différenciée selon ces
secteurs d'activités on constate de
fortes attentes et déceptions exprimées
quant à l'orientation des l'école et on
peut s'interroger de savoir pourquoi
tant de personnes quittent certains
de l'hôtellerie restauration si on est
un exemple mais c'est pas ce n'est pas
le seul
l'orientation et la formation initiale
sans évidemment également en cause dans
leur efficience et comme je le dis
souligné tout à l'heure la question de
l'attractivité avec une problématique de
classification de rémunération de
capacité à évoluer professionnellement
et des conditions de travail qui sont
mises en cause qui doivent mieux prendre
en compte
les
ces questions là doivent être prises en
compte pardon dans les dans les
politiques de branches et les pratiques
des entreprises
alors la crise sanitaire elle-même était
porteuse remise en question
professionnelle c'est à dire que les
gens ont eu le temps de réfléchir et
quelque part de
s'intéresser à exercer une autre
activité je vous je vous apprends rien
en soulignant que on dispose aujourd'hui
en France de tous les instruments
permettant de le faire que ce soit le
bilan de compétences le conseil en
évolution professionnelle ou les
dispositifs d'accompagnement à la
reconversion avec
la mobilisation du réseau des
associations de transition
professionnelle
voilà donc
ensuite des données démographiques
également qui sont intéressantes
publiées par France stratégie et qui
sont préoccupantes puisque la ressource
sera refinie et le premier accès à
l'emploi se trouve décalé par la
poursuite d'études en soulignant
d'ailleurs sur ce point que la poursuite
d'études
concerne la tranche d'âge 14-24 ans pour
42%
ce qui est déjà un élément extrêmement
important et que en 2030 France
stratégie définit cette proportion à
hauteur de 48% autrement dit les jeunes
en capacité de rentrer sur marché du
travail
seront encore moins nombreux
qu'aujourd'hui avec une
[Musique]
en volume de jeunes dans cette tranche
d'âge qui
ne croit pas
d'amis en débouché sur des diagnostics
partagés avec les partenaires sociaux
dans les branches concernées donc les
branches étaient
la métallurgie les métiers de bouche les
transports le secteur du conseil en
numérique et le secteur du bâtiment tous
pour toutes ces branches les métiers
concernés étaient des métiers de
production jusqu'au niveau petite
maîtrise c'était la cible prioritaire
définie par par les partenaires sociaux
agir pour résorber les difficultés
recrutement c'est agir simultanément sur
plusieurs facteurs la promotion de la
profession la préparation des jeunes
générations il faut intégrer les jeunes
et adultes disponibles pour un emploi et
agir sur la qualité de vie au travail
resserrer les liens avec les cols
resserrer les liens avec tous ces
emplois
fluidifier les politiques de formation
et améliorer leur qualité et enfin
développer l'apprentissage et piloter
piloter ce dispositif qui est un
processus comme vous l'avez compris qui
donc interactif alors la temporalité
n'est pas la même pour des jeunes et
pour des personnes qui sont disponibles
pour travailler mais il est important
d'agir simultanément sur tous ces
facteurs de façon à pas perdre de temps
y compris vis-à-vis des publics qui sont
en situation de scolarisation et qui
sont les salariés de demain
voilà donc après on a on a des plans
d'action qui ont été construits
généralement sur les mêmes les mêmes
modèles avec les partenaires sociaux
qui reprennent ces éléments sur la
problématique de l'orientation vers dans
la relation école entreprise
j'ai travaillé sur l'attractivité et les
rémunérations et la qualité de vie au
travail dans le cas de la négociation
collective donc au cours des 18 mois de
mission
certaines certains secteurs se sont
engagés dans un processus de négociation
avec succès c'était le cas par exemple
dans le dans la branche du conseil sur
le champ du numérique ça a été le cas
également dans le secteur des transports
et donc dans les travaux que j'ai remis
où vous pourrez trouver les éléments
très précis
concernant ces négociations qui
intéressaient pas seulement les
problématiques de rémunération mais
également la qualité de vie au travail
qui est un élément essentiel et
particulièrement la conciliation vie
familiale vie professionnelle qui
intéresse particulièrement les les
jeunes entrant sur le marché du travail
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
qui en fin de compte pour des raisons
liées à la disponibilité de leur budget
annuel ne sont pas vraiment intégrés
dans un processus suffisamment anticipé
et ce qui provoque ce qui provoque
quelques quelques difficultés
d'applications sur le terrain donc ça
fait partie des préconisations que
naturellement nous avons partagé quand
je précise qu'il faut anticiper ajuster
et réguler l'effort de formation en fin
de compte il faut faire un travail
programmatique plus d'un an à l'avance
et bien sûr assurer des mises à jour
régulières auprès des acteurs qui sont
acheteurs et organisateurs de ces de ces
efforts de formation
et puis bien sûr la question des
pilotage est importante et pour vous
donner un exemple
vous devez avoir entendu parler de cette
démarche qui s'appelle l'industrie
recrute en Bretagne et qui réunit autour
des acteurs de l'industrie et notamment
de la branche métallurgie le rectorat
Pôle emploi la région dans chaque bassin
d'emploi et ce travail permet à la fois
d'agir en amont sur la sensibilisation
et la connaissance des métiers et on
avale sur la régulation des dispositifs
permettant de répondre aux besoins des
entreprises et des populations et ce que
j'ai observé c'est que cette démarche
permet de multiplier par 3 les résultats
qu'on constate habituellement dans
d'autres secteurs
avec des méthodes qui qui sont beaucoup
moins pilotées et réguliers
collectivement donc il y a un vrai sujet
en fait ce dialogue à l'échelle locale
entre les différents autorités que j'ai
cité
les recommandations pour finir
[Musique]
je vais pas toutes les prendre en compte
simplement dire que ce qui était
important c'est que les observatoires de
branches qui portent sur des contenus du
métier et de leur place des audience
doit partager donc là on a une
initiative intéressante de France
compétences avec la grande bibliothèque
qui vient d'être mise en place
peut-être permettre justement de
observatoire existant en France de
partager ces données avec tous les
acteurs concernés y compris avec le
grand public d'ailleurs on y trouve des
informations de grande de grande
intérêts sur le contenu des emplois et
leurs évolutions
qu'on s'oublie dès le dialogue entre les
branches professionnelles les régions
les rectorats et Pôle emploi je viens
d'en parler à la fois sur la politique
d'orientation scolaire et
professionnelle mais aussi la politique
de formation initiale et continue
pour les demandeurs d'emploi par exemple
veillez ce que
représente territoriale de proximité
dans les territoires c'est pas toujours
le cas où les personnes qui représentent
les secteurs professionnels ne sont pas
toujours mandatés par la branche au
niveau national ce qui peut poser des
difficultés
et puis mettre en place des protocoles
de liaison entre les entreprises et les
services notamment services publics de
l'emploi donc là on est sur des
approches assez assez classiques qui
sont pas forcément liés à la négociation
de branches mais qui sont plus liées à
de bonnes pratiques permettant un
dialogue territorial construit de
qualité
et puis les branches sont invitées à
promouvoir et développer l'apprentissage
et la professionnalisation et améliorer
les dispositifs d'intégration de suivi
en entreprise
de veiller à ce que les indicateurs
qualités du référentiel national qualité
caliopie soit appliqués de façon à
réduire les abandons autrement dit
s'intéresser à une qualité d'intégration
des jeunes dans les entreprises pour ne
pas gaspiller ces ressources qui sont
comme je le disais de plus en plus rare
parce que tout le monde cherche la même
chose
et puis merci
monsieur on a on a bien on a bien
apprécié la présentation de des éléments
de votre rapport sur tous les
préconisations on y reviendra à travers
les questions certainement vous restez
en ligne avec nous et vous vous entendez
les interventions
qui se font dans notre salle de réunion
alors je vais donner la parole à Madame
berther pour tes questions
oui merci monsieur président merci
beaucoup pour vos interventions monsieur
doll vous nous parliez des jeunes et de
cette nécessité de leur donner une
meilleure connaissance de tous les
métiers qui existent d'avoir plus de
liens entre entre entreprises branche et
éducation nationale finalement et puis
également de
pouvoir
lors d'un premier emploi être un peu
plus en adéquation avec finalement les
formations que que nos jeunes ont eu
donc sur ces aspects là et aussi sur
l'aspect alors que des entreprises que
nous avons auditionnées nous ont
transmises concernant les nouvelles
générations qui ont donc cette approche
différente du travail avec plus de
mobilité mais aussi un regard plus
important et vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
sur les valeurs de l'entreprise donc
peut-être une RSE puisque nous suivons
ce travail depuis plusieurs années au
niveau de
entreprises une RSE qui va permettre un
meilleur recrutement ou voilà quel est
votre votre avis à ce sujet et Madame
quintini et Monsieur Dupas Amaury quel
est justement votre regard par rapport à
ce qui vient d'être dit sur cette
nécessité d'une mise en adéquation des
formations d'avoir de connaître tout le
panel des métiers pour nos jeunes
lorsqu'ils sont en formation et bien sûr
de ce premier emploi qui est toujours
important et parfois qui est en décalage
avec ce qu'ils ont pu faire même assez
souvent donc quel regard avez-vous là
dessus merci beaucoup alors on va
commencer dans la salle si vous voulez
madame Cathy
[Musique]
aussi beaucoup de il y a beaucoup
d'éléments très intéressants très vrai
dans ce que vous disiez
de mon côté je pense je vais rajouter
peut-être ce qui a été déjà dit que
alors la
disons le conseil en évolution
professionnelle la tout ce qui est
habilan de compétences orientation Bruce
c'est très important pour les jeunes
mais c'est aussi important pour les
adultes et d'une certaine façon les deux
sont liés parce qu'on constate souvent
que une bonne orientation
professionnelle pendant l'école ça veut
dire une expérience positive d'accès à
ces services ce qui fait que après les
adultes continuent à accéder à ce
service parce qu'ils en ont eu une
expérience positive avec toutes les
reconversions professionnelles qu'on
s'attend plus fréquente dans la vie
professionnelle aussi dans une
professionnelle plus longue avec le
vieillissement de la population c'est
très important qu'il y ait un contenu
tout au long de la carrière tout au long
de la vie vous êtes accès à des
informations comme je le disais avant
beaucoup d'adultes ne se forment pas
parce qu'ils ne savent pas identifier
ils ne voient pas ils sont pas motivés
ne voient pas l'intérêt de la formation
ou sinon ils ont pas su identifier tout
seul une formation qui soit adaptée à
leur besoin donc cet élément de
conseils d'orientation professionnelle
de d'avoir un expert devant nous qui
nous aide à faire le bilan qui nous
disent quels sont les métiers émergents
et dans lesquels on peut reconvertir nos
compétences c'est très important un
autre élément qui me viennent à l'esprit
dans votre question et les propos qu'on
a entendus c'est que effectivement la
transition de l'école à l'emploi est
très importante mais il faut pas oublier
justement que les jeunes sont intéressés
à la mobilité comme vous veniez de le
dire dans vos questionnaires aux
entreprises mais aussi que qu'il aime ou
pas ça va être un marché du travail
avait beaucoup plus de changements de
celui qu'on a connu nous donc ça veut
dire effectivement qu'on doit aussi le
préparer dans le long terme donc tout ce
qui est
évidemment ce qui a été dit extrêmement
vrai en terme de voilà
mélange d'apprentissage en classe
apprentissage en entreprise tout ce qui
est formation professionnelle etc ce
qu'on constate quand même que souvent
dans ces filières il y a moins de
formations de base ce qui fait que
finalement l'entrée sur le marché du
travail est très facilité mais après
donc les transitions se font plus
difficiles parce que c'est plus
difficile on les a formés en métier très
spécifique avec des compétences
excellentes et qui lui ont permis de
trouver un emploi beaucoup plus
facilement que d'autres qui ont fait des
études plus générales mais et on sait
tous qu'il y a des pénuries dans tous
les professions en plus
d'une techniciens plombier électricien
etc je parle des exemples classiques
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait après une fois
que ces emplois sont en partie
automatisés où il faut apprendre à
travailler avec les machines souvent les
gens qu'on a préparé pour ce métier on
les a pas préparés à se reformer à
reprendre la formation donc ça c'est un
peu ce que ce que j'ai envie de rajouter
à ce qui a été dit réponse à votre
question
[Musique]
de mon côté je vais rebondir sur
certains éléments il y avait plusieurs
éléments dans votre question d'abord je
rebondis sur le volet RSE et qui pour
moi en fait
voilà en filigrane on sent la question
du sens la question aussi de l'écart
générationnel effectivement on met en
avant la question du sens dans cette
nouvelle équation de la rétention
notamment chez les jeunes régénérations
ce qui m'étonne toujours dans de comment
dire de je ne sais pas en tout cas
uniquement se dire que ces jeunes
générations sont en quête de sens et que
les anciennes n'en avaient aucun je
pense juste que les équilibres changent
que on a toujours comment dire construit
un sens par rapport à ce qu'on fait à la
fois dans notre vie privée dans notre
vie professionnelle
c'est et je pense que en fait la
question du sens de la RSE c'est à la
fois une partie de la solution et du
problème en fait
donc la crise sanitaire ça a été un
moment de révélation sur l'interrogation
au cours sur le marché du travail pour
ceux qui ont eu le luxe d'y penser parce
que effectivement on parle de beaucoup
de comment dire de catégories
socio-professionnelles ici il y a ceux
qui voilà qui étaient qui étaient au
front et je pense qu'ils n'ont pas eu
l'occasion beaucoup d'y penser ou alors
après et effectivement il y a d'autres
populations qui ont eu qui ont eu ce
luxe
en creux on peut voir une contestation
de la valeur identitaire du travail et
des velléités d'une relation plus
équilibrée
mais en fait tout ça ça se mêle à
maintenant des tentatives de ce que
j'appellerais en fait de sens washing
vous connaissez le greenwashing donc
dire qu'on fait des investissements
verts ou quelque chose comme ça et
maintenant en fait les entreprises ont
compris que c'était une partie de la
solution de la rétention notamment des
jeunes et donc vont vendre du sens
jusqu'à ce qu'il y en ait absolument
plus je travaille avec les organisations
je n'ai jamais rencontré une
organisation qui m'a dit ce qu'on fait
n'a aucun sens
donc voilà je crois que mais comme pour
la RSE il faut distinguer le grain de
livret et se dire voilà qu'est-ce qu'il
y a du sens etc sachant que encore une
fois c'est une construction à
l'interface de l'individuel et du
collectif donc voilà je me méfie
toujours de ces de ces tentatives de
mettre le sens au centre c'est une
partie de l'équation en revanche encore
une fois on est face à des subjectivités
donc c'est compliqué de répondre en
généralité et pareil enfin c'est comme
pour la transition écologique c'est à
dire qu'est-ce qui est fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait concrètement etc donc c'est
le même problématique et je pense qu'il
faut il faut pas trop être naïf non plus
il y a beaucoup d'artifices voilà donc
il faut voir précisément
ce qui est en jeu ce que j'ai beaucoup
aimé aussi dans l'intervention de
Monsieur Dolls c'est effectivement mais
ça je pense qu'on est tous conscient
c'est le poids démesuré de la formation
initiale qui rend difficile l'accès à
l'information et à la bifurcation
et justement
les études montrent que
même chez les diplômés des plus grandes
écoles en fait on se retrouve face à un
éventail particulièrement étroit
d'option professionnelle donc c'est à
dire que toutes les catégories sont
touchées et vous avez des chercheurs aux
États-Unis des sociologues qui vont
identifier donc ce phénomène d'entonnoir
à carrière et il se pose une question
très naïve
mais à la fois naïve et brillante c'est
dans ces écoles qui ouvrent toutes les
portes pourquoi à la sortie les gens ne
font que deux trois métiers
et ben dans ces grandes écoles vous
pouvez dire avec avec certitude ce que
vont faire vos étudiants à la fin et
donc ils vont dégager dégager des
mécanismes dans ces populations d'élite
hein
ce sont des phénomènes sociologiques il
faudrait voir comment ils s'emporte chez
nous mais globalement ces mécanismes
peuvent se retrouver et ils vont mettre
l'accent en fait sur la Mallet mala et
malléabilité pardon des étudiants
déclencher en fait par le manque de
connaissances sur l'éventail des
carrières possibles même chez ces
étudiants d'élite
un esprit de compétition qui est
alimenté alors ça c'est particulier chez
eux du fait de leur positionnement
relatif sur le marché du travail mais
avec cette frénésie de recrutement etc
et l'intériorisation en fait de niveau
de prestige différencié des carrières
professionnelles qui vont jouer en fait
sur des insécurités ils vont chercher
quelque chose qui est digne de leur
diplôme etc
et en fait si vous voulez chez eux c'est
un peu la traduction de l'extension
professionnelle d'un bon et levisme qui
consiste en fait à faire ce qui est
attendu de vous voilà donc même chez ces
populations d'élite en fait si vous
voulez il y a vraiment cet entonnoir
extrêmement puissant et même chez eux le
coût de faire une bifurcation est énorme
du fait voilà de ce qui vient avec tout
ce prestige qu'ils ont voilà qui qu'ils
ont
accumulé et après une fois en entreprise
vous avez d'autres mécanismes qui vont
prendre un peu le relais donc des
mécanismes de rétention etc
et comment dire si alors moi mes
recherches portent plutôt sur ces
populations là mais ces mécanismes vont
en fait se retrouver chez d'autres
populations mais avec une position
impositionnement sur le marché du
travail bien différent
voilà un peu moins entre guillemets
luxueux mais en revanche vous allez
retrouver les trois tests des choix
perçus accès à l'information etc et ça
vient vraiment mais mais là c'est voilà
c'est
plein de choses c'est une détermination
mais qui qui vient enfin initialement
voilà c'est c'est une détermination
sociale c'est un accès à l'information
c'est aussi encore une fois il y a des
retenues psychologiques par rapport à
cette formation et cet environnement
initial on sait que beaucoup de gens ont
cette envie de bifurquer en revanche on
voit que le pourcentage est beaucoup
moins élevé ceux qui passent à l'action
parce qu'il y a plein de freins et les
principaux freins ils sont aussi
psychologiques c'est-à-dire que je suis
sûr qu'on a tous les outils pour
bifurquer en revanche est-ce qu'on pense
vraiment qu'on peut le faire et ce qu'on
peut vraiment le faire après avoir passé
voilà pour certaines catégories ce cap
des 20 ans et de cette voilà de de cette
voix qui est devant nous de cet
autoroute
et je pense qu'on se pose beaucoup plus
la question parce que les carrières sont
beaucoup plus fragmentées
et donc voilà la question se pose encore
plus il y a des il y a des comment dire
des récits reconversion spectaculaire
mais c'est extrêmement
compliqué de faire cette démarche quand
bien même on a les outils tout
simplement parce que et je pense que on
peut quand même parler pas d'une
spécificité française parce que
relativement vous pourriez trouver ça
dans d'autres pays mais
quand même j'ai l'impression que on est
particulièrement sujet à ce genre de
comment dire de d'autoroute dans le sens
où voilà ce que vous avez étudié en fait
à l'université va déterminer ce que vous
pouvez faire alors que par exemple dans
des pays anglo-saxons vous pouvez avoir
étudié je sais pas l'histoire
intellectuelle au XIXe siècle et faire
de la finance comment voulez-vous faire
ça ici c'est impossible
c'est pas impossible je veux dire c'est
un coup énorme
et c'est pas dans les mentalités donc
oui je pense que on a vraiment cet effet
entonnoir et qu'on fait et en fait si
vous voulez on produit un désir de de
faire voilà ces carrières là mais pareil
pour comment dire les classes ouvrières
où il y avait d'anciennes recherches qui
montrait que en fait on apprenait à
vouloir à désirer à désirer et ça ça
veut dire que voilà on s'auto et conduit
de certaines voies mais on apprend à
désirer et on est bien là où on est donc
voilà c'est cet apprentissage qui se
fait au long cours et qui liée à plein
de choses et notamment à l'environnement
familial à l'information etc mais oui et
et et honnêtement j'ai pas de solution
miracle
voilà
je suis d'accord évidemment avec ce que
Monsieur tu parles disait mais c'est
vrai qu'on a qu'en partie c'est un peu
aussi de la façon dont laquelle on
raisonne toujours autour de métiers
plutôt que de compétences donc ce qu'on
a fait je pense on fait un peu partout
les gouvernement commence à l'intégrer
pour l'emploi et les autres les autres
équivalents de Pôle emploi à l'étranger
on commence à réfléchir aux professions
comme
un ensemble de tâches et de compétences
et donc la reconversion n'est pas aussi
difficile qu'elle peut le sembler
c'est-à-dire on ne demande pas aux
adultes parce que ça sera très compliqué
comme mon collègue vient de le dire de
demander à quelqu'un de retourner à
l'université se réformer pour encore 4
ans et après commencer dans une autre
profession entièrement différente mais
il y a des transitions qui peuvent se
faire qui peuvent paraître quand on
regarde la profession lointaine mais en
fait quand on regarde les
les aptitudes qui sont nécessaires il y
a des parallèles et donc on peut
justement
identifier les déficit de compétences ce
qui manque et c'est formé sur ce qui
manque sur des formations beaucoup plus
courtes beaucoup plus adaptées aux
besoins des adultes
alors
ce dont parlait c'était surtout des
adultes traqualifiés qui sortaient de
grandes écoles ou de Harvard des Stephen
discours un peu différent mais si on
réfléchit à des adultes qui sont qui ont
déjà une expérience relativement
disons que on débarque qualifications
donc probablement une expérience pas
très positive de l'école alors lui
demander de se reformer de passer deux
ans au-delà même de l'implications
financières qui peut qui peut qui peut y
être pour eux parce que c'est quand même
un peu qualifié peut payer etc mais si
on lui demande par contre de faire un
cours de se reformer plus court de
quelques semaines d'un mois seulement
pour se focaliser sur les faiblesses et
sur ce qui peut lui permettre de après
basculer sur des sont plus prometteur ça
ça devient plus faisable donc je pense
que ça fait donc c'est c'est la
mentalité qui change des entreprises des
particuliers et aussi de tout de tous
les institutions qui facilitent cette
transition et compris par exemple
l'emploi et je sais que pour l'emploi
est quand même un des
disons des des services publics de
l'emploi qui a mis en avant cette
approche vraiment de dire ok de vous
êtes chômeur quelles sont les
compétences du chômeur plutôt que juste
l'histoire professionnelle et pour les
entreprises d'exprimer leurs besoins en
termes de compétences pas seulement un
terme de profession parce qu'il puisse
pour qu'on puisse considérer un ensemble
plus élargi à la fois de profession et
de candidats et en plus je pense que ça
peut aussi permettre d'adresser certains
disons pénurie qui peuvent être des
vrais pénuries c'est-à-dire de pénurie
dû au fait qu'il y a peu de personnes
formées vraiment pour cet emploi on peut
choisir d'autres à partir d'autres
catégories professionnelles avec un peu
de formation qui accompagne une
transition de ce métier à celui qui a un
pénurie par exemple
merci alors je vais donner la parole à
Florence blatrix compta pour question
rapporteur et puis ensuite à nos
collègues fera
un tir groupé des questions que vous
pourriez avoir pour conclure donc
Florence pour commencer puis
merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
le sujet du contrat psychologique qui en
effet très important mais voilà comment
est-ce que on peut avoir à partir d'un
contrat psychologique qui a une part
quand même individuelle construire des
politiques publiques
à partir de voilà à partir de cela avoir
une action globale en prenant en compte
ce contrat psychologique comment est-ce
qu'il faut en définir les les dimensions
que vous évoquez aussi la question du
sens alors la question du sens elle est
pas nouvelle elle avait été abordée par
David gremer par les bullshites chobs et
en fait une entreprise peut avoir du
sens et des emplois au sein de cette
entreprise peuvent aussi ne pas en avoir
par exemple récemment une étude a été
publiée sur les réunions dont un certain
nombre seraient finalement pas
extrêmement
utile donc est-ce que les organisations
aussi s'interrogent sur en interne
comment est-ce qu'on donne du sens au
travail
voilà est-ce que c'est quelque chose
aussi qui pourrait permettre permettre
de motiver les salariés est-ce qu'elle a
notion de salaire déficience qui avait
été
évoqué voilà par des économistes
il y a quelques années
a toujours du sens aujourd'hui pour ceux
qui recherchent un emploi est-ce que
finalement derrière le manque de sens et
plein d'autres reproches sur l'emploi il
y a pas finalement le salaire qui ne
serait pas jugé suffisant et tout ça
c'est aussi lié aux questions de aux
questions de pouvoir d'achat donc je
vais pas aller sur d'autres sujets parce
que je peux laisser mes collègues aussi
peut-être poser des questions
sur les sur les questions de notre
rapporteur allez-y peut-être oui oui du
coup effectivement graveur posait la
question du de la construction du sens
individuel plutôt chez les cols blancs
il l'aura appelé ça comme ça
je
rebondis plus sur qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire déjà on peut reconnaître qu'il y a
pas de meilleur organisation en absolu
en revanche j'imagine qu'on peut mettre
en place des politiques publiques pour
voilà
comment dire
améliorer les possibilités de mettre en
place voilà du télétravail la semaine de
quatre jours etc sachant que
toutes ces ce volet organisationnels qui
je pense est très important
n'est pas bon en soi et qui doit
toujours être en fait
contextualiser dans un secteur dans une
entreprise c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile aussi de dire des généralités
mais par exemple le télétravail c'est
pas quelque chose qui est bon en soi si
on permet le télétravail et par exemple
ça permet une reproduction d'une
division genre je sais pas du ménage etc
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose
d'extrêmement positif si ça sert à ça la
semaine de quatre jours si vous êtes
dans une entreprise vous vous sentez pas
comment dire psychologiquement bien dans
votre travail il y a les cinq jours ou
quatre jours vous y allez il y a en
gagner un peu mais c'est pas voilà c'est
pas quelque chose de comment dire de de
réjouissant
en fait il faut réfléchir en tout cas
sur le volet organisationnel qui est
vraiment important pour moi comme on
réfléchit à un mix énergétique en fait
on a un mix d'énergie énergétique avec
voilà comment dire notre pays fonctionne
avec voilà tant de % de nucléaire etc en
fait voilà c'est plutôt la compatibilité
et l'équilibre entre les différents
dispositifs
d'organisation du travail que ce soit en
temps de travail vous parlez de
déficience je pense totalement que que
c'est une partie d'équation c'est une
seule partie de l'équation comme comme
je vous l'ai dit un autre levier qui me
paraît important c'est c'est comment
dire la redéfinition du management et
notamment alors je sais que ça paraît
très angélique mais en fait non je pense
que c'est très pragmatique surtout en ce
moment c'est voilà le Ker management
pour susciter en fait un engagement
positif au travail et ça nécessite de
former les managers de comment dire de
voilà de communiquer sur ces manières de
manager qui en fait vont permettre non
pas que le manager devienne le
psychologue de ses salariés c'est pas du
tout ça mais juste qu'il est ce socle de
compétences et voilà et savoir ce qui se
passe comment et voilà et aussi ces
manières de manager
je pense que c'est vraiment un levier
organisationnel extrêmement puissant et
qui va se jouer au long cours etc mais
je voilà je pense aussi que c'est que
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'important
et oui sur la question du sens c'est
c'est oui c'est quelque chose de très de
très subjectif donc ça fait partie de
l'équation mais voilà c'est on est
encore dans la matière humaine donc
c'est très compliqué de de faire des
généralités mais pour moi
si vous voulez il y a
il y a plusieurs choses c'est c'est donc
le volet organisationnel la redéfinition
du contrat psychologique donc avec
chacun des leviers dont on a pu parler
lors de cette séance et une redéfinition
du management avec de nouvelles
techniques beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
modernes et je pense que en tout cas on
peut pas freiner
le la mutation au long cours en revanche
on peut l'accompagner et susciter
l'engagement de ces manières là
merci alors je me tourne vers les
collègues qui sont
est-ce que vous avez des questions pas
de question si ce qui perd et ce qui en
aura d'autres questions c'est une
remarque pardonnez-moi
j'ai pas entendu du tout depuis deux
le mot aimer son travail
on peut pas travailler sous contrainte
mais comment faire pour inciter les gens
à trouver un travail puisqu'il y en a il
y a des je pense que trouver du travail
aujourd'hui celui qui veut il trouve
d'aimer là où on est et ça c'est pas
quelque chose qui qui s'organise ces
entreprises qui récemment cette relation
et je crois que le fait d'aller sur le
télétravail psychologiquement
rond
l'intérêt d'être dans l'entreprise et
d'aimer justement et d'échanger donc il
y a une rupture qui ne crée pas l'esprit
d'entreprise
et qui ne facilite pas justement
l'emploi
est-ce que les formations peuvent aider
justement
à ce que les gens aillent là où il faut
bien orienter etc et apprécier ce qu'ils
font et ne pas aller comme les chiens
battus pour travailler
merci Pierrot à prendre aussi
Vincent Vincent si tu veux
oui
juste
on entend de plus en plus
enfin ma question c'est est-ce que on
n'est pas est-ce qu'on ne paye pas les
effets de la culture de l'élite
permanente je m'explique
quand dans les jeunes ils veulent gagner
de l'argent très vite
ils sont ils sont attirés par les
startups
parce que c'est il baigne dans ce monde
là et donc ils se disent gagner de
l'argent sans faire trop d'efforts
et puis au bout d'un moment il
s'aperçoivent que ben il y a qu'une
petite proportion qui va pouvoir
bénéficier de
cette villa on met jamais la lumière sur
ceux qui se lèvent le matin qui vont
travailler qui ont du plaisir à
travailler qui ont une situation de
famille qui ont une fierté qui élève
leurs enfants on n'est jamais sur la on
n'a jamais la mise en lumière des gens
simples qui compensent 85% de la
population française on a toujours cette
lumière sur la sur l'élite
et quand
ils ont pas quand ils voient d'arriver à
l'élite c'est juste pas possible ils se
disent ben tout compte fait si je suis
au chômage et puis si j'ai les aides
sociales je vais vivre presque aussi
bien est-ce qu'on paye pas aujourd'hui
cette cette vision des choses
est-ce que est-ce que le goût de
l'effort est resté le même est-ce que
est-ce qu'il s'entretient enfin vous
avez plus ou moins répondu à ces
questions là vous parlez tout à on
apprenait à désirer maintenant est-ce
que on apprend toujours à digérer c'est
sûrement pas le cas
merci alors donc on va conclure en
répondant à ces ultimes questions oui
madame
c'est plutôt des remarques que des
questions je pense
[Musique]
d'améliorer le Conseil d'évolution
professionnelle à disons la carrière
comme on l'appelle pour les adultes
souvent
la vision l'orientation pour les adultes
se fait au sein des services publics de
l'emploi ce qui fait que c'est très
utilitaire c'est perçu que très
utilisable parce que forcément c'est ça
le but du service public de l'emploi de
prendre les chômeurs et de lui trouver
un emploi qui qui apporte plus ou moins
selon les systèmes il y a parfois des
contraintes que ça on doit rester dans
l'emploi ou un certain nombre de mois
mais c'est toujours utilitaire et donc
c'est moi adapté à
aux transition où on doit vraiment
comprendre ce que la personne peut faire
ce que la personne intéressée sur quel
emploient être intéressés à basculer
quel est l'effort qu'elle doit faire lui
faire comprendre le motiver etc à faire
cet effort donc je pense que là c'est un
peu où je vois le lien avec votre propos
qui est très raisonnable et avec ce
qu'on a dit jusqu'à maintenant qu'il y a
il y a toujours cet élément de faire
ainsi que les gens choisissent quand
même quelque chose
qu'ils avaient après il y a l'effort du
management comme on l'a dit et de
l'entreprise dans la motivation je
reviens sur le point que je fais avant
je vais pas les répéter mais je pense
qu'il y a effectivement des formes
d'organiser le travail qui sont plus
motivantes qui qui sont qui dansent plus
de de possibilités aux employés de
s'investir dans le travail et donc
d'aimer ce qu'ils font parce qu'ils
apprennent en continuation parce qu'ils
ont ils ont des des moyens de de
voilà de d'avoir plus d'autonomie plus
de d'intérêt pour ceux qui font
[Musique]
quand on pose la question en fait
d'aimer son travail
je dirais que voilà il y a des emplois
qui sont plus facilement aimables que
d'autres
par exemple voilà être chercheur c'est
relativement simple d'aimer son métier
etc il y aura toujours une frange de la
population en fait pour qui ce n'est pas
une question on travaille pour subvenir
à ses besoins etc la question n'est pas
d'aimer en revanche là où ça devient
problématique c'est ou des métiers
aimables par exemple je pense à la santé
en fait on n'aime plus travailler parce
que les conditions sont telles que et
quand je rencontre ce genre de
population ou ça pourrait être évident
le rôle social qu'ils ont séparé pour
les professeurs dans les collèges etc en
fait les conditions de travail font que
même eux cette utilité sociale
incroyable qu'ils ont pour nous en fait
il ne peuvent plus le faire ils s'en
vont et d'ailleurs c'est c'est l'un des
secteurs où les gens s'en vont la santé
parce que les conditions de travail font
que on n'arrive plus à aimer son travail
parce qu'on n'arrive plus à le faire il
y a un dilemme il y a un dilemme
c'est c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est à dire
que c'est un accélérateur des tendances
longues et c'est
oui c'était déjà avant mais surtout
après covid il y a eu un effet parce
qu'on a vraiment mis la lumière on a dit
le travail pénible etc etc et alors que
plutôt de les mettre en avant etc enfin
on l'a eu cette période là mais après on
est vraiment passé en disant c'est
pénible c'est pénible c'est pénible
c'était répétitif je vous dis
l'information est toujours négative quoi
c'est c'est un thé un peu mais oui et
c'est ce que Coralie Perez aurait dit
voilà c'est c'est le dilemme éthique en
fait c'est à dire que on aime faire son
travail on aime l'activité qu'on fait
mais on a plus les moyens de le faire et
du coup ça ça vous met dans un état
absolument absolument intenable et du
coup voilà vous vous pouvez plus faire
votre activité je voudrais juste
rebondir sur le côté élitiste
effectivement c'est une des modalités
aussi de traduction de la grande
démission chez nous c'est à dire qu'on a
mis le coup de projecteur chez des
cadres ou chez voilà des jeunes diplômés
etc c'est en soi intéressant cette
traduction qui a eu lieu chez nous et je
suis d'accord qu'il faut voilà voir ce
panel de manière un peu plus large et
j'ai parlé de cette population là parce
que mes recherches portent sur eux mais
je suis totalement d'accord avec vous
sur voilà le fait de et je crois que
c'est aussi le sens voilà des des
middles middle skills etc et je pense
que c'est extrêmement intéressant et et
c'était assez conclu complémentaire du
coup
[Musique]
et de la formation à distance merci
beaucoup madame monsieur